good morning it is Monday and I'm not
wearing any makeup today because I am
mostly out of chicks to give today I
have a really exciting guest on not too
deep it's someone that I I really like I
think she is really funny I think she's
really brave she's someone that's not
afraid to give her opinions got a really
great attitude really positive really
beautiful and amazing hair and amazingly
loves dogs more than me which is a very
difficult thing to do but she definitely
loves them more than I do so I thought
it'd be really appropriate to let my dog
goose introduce this week's guest on not
too deep goose say the name say the name
of the guest say the name of the guest
say use your words say the name of the
guest say the name say the name of the
guest please please say the name of the
guest goose please say the name of the
guest goose please say the name of the
guest out loud with English or Spanish
whatever you prefer goes please say the
name of the gasps Wow that was exactly
what you're expecting to be a camera on
the entire table you want to see a
camera on the tired dog it's been
happening this whole time this week's
guest on the podcast is Brittany Furlan
she is so wonderful and we had a really
great conversation and here are a few of
my favorite parts from that conversation
we're going we're going we're doing it
guys I'm here with Brittany Furlan yeah
what's the heritage Italian yeah it's
for London there you go you just throw a
meatball at me when you say you're very
honest about all the situations that
you're going through without going into
too much detail and also the dogs and
the dogs so it's mostly for the dogs
which I didn't know
Wiki is the the Yorkie and the older one
yeah I thought she was younger or he no
he's like 10 Wiki can like barely home
first of all Winkie like peas the bed
like every night I'm like I tried to put
diapers on wiki-like choose a lot
embarrassing dog moment oh my god I've
had too many embarrassed about the first
time I got Nina I was in Bed Bath &
Beyond and I put her in my Prada bag
like a [ __ ] okay and she's a puppy and
I was walking around by Bath and Beyond
I was like this lady kept kind of
following me because we were both just
looking at the same stature it smelled
[ __ ] smell the fart smells like farting
lady will not get away from me I was
farting it's lady giving her dirty looks
I thought it was she was farting I liked
she continuously crossing me and I know
it you've dropped us to me forty five
times so I walk away and I still smell
the [ __ ] snow and I'm like oh my god and
I looked down in my bag and Nina's just
looking up at me and I lift her out and
the bottom half of her body is just
caked all over the back like it was
discovery thing in the bag was covered
and [ __ ] the entire bag it was just like
it just looked like someone smashed a
Hershey bar like maybe like 50 Hershey
bars I was like oh my god oh god and the
bag couldn't get cleaned it was done it
was ruined that was like took my dog
technically cost like $3,000 I was
looking at shoes in Nordstrom yeah and
Nina was on the leash every time like I
can't breathe wicked anywhere he shits
everyone Nina shit's everywhere on some
shoes I didn't really want to buy any
shoes I'm sure none of these are working
out whatever yeah I look over
Nina's shitty like right next to a pair
of Manolo I'm like oh my god she's
sitting next to the Manolo Blahniks the
guy in the suits just standing there
like staring at me so she takes this
giant [ __ ] on the rug next like these
really nice shoes and I don't want to
buy any shoes that day I'm like I'll
take all four pairs of shoes like I
bought all the shoes just cuz I was so
embarrassed dogs are expensive but they
love you forever so worth it like I
don't even care she could [ __ ] anywhere
are you into fashion now as I do I love
fashion I've always loved fashion so
that was like my backup would you ever
design clothes fashions very snobby yeah
I was like unless shirt you know
especially Agni coming off of vine
they're like oh this Viner wants to make
it oh yeah what is it gonna be a vine
skirt like there's like degrading is it
gonna be made out of vinyl do more than
one thing you special don't let them
keep you down dj khaled have you had any
weird movie-going experiences like you
got a red carpet events and stuff like
that at times I get invited to a lot but
I always feel really cheesy I'm not that
person who will like go on the red
carpet for a film that I'm not in
exactly the whole idea of red carpets it
makes me laugh yes this weird little
world where you're asking all these
strangers who are screaming at you to
take your photo and to document you
attending it's just horrifying
yeah as someone
anxiety it's the weirdest thing is when
they scream different poses that oh yeah
like jump look over your shoulder give
me a thumbs up yeah you're just like
what fingering yourself how is just
adults yelling another adult it's so
like I literally be a puppet and yeah
none of them like they don't treat you
nicely no but I imagine like what is
there what are their lives like because
they get paid for those pictures like
[ __ ] this is my paycheck like don't
like I'm gonna take your picture but you
can't do it right worst moments are when
you go and you stand and they're like
who are you oh yeah that happens to me
Wow yeah I'll pretend to check their
cell phone so they don't take your
[ __ ] up you're like I have to like
slowly shuffle down I was walking on the
red carpet and and this they were like
Brittany Franz nominated for streaming
for Brian over here it was like a huge
I'm I'm gonna say who they are yeah they
were like no we're good we don't want to
talk to her it was like and that is like
a piece of Hiromi absolutely this is a
meat market and I'm weird gross old
brisket make sure you go follow Brittany
on all your social media platforms her
snapchat story is hilarious it's really
is really a good time if you're into
good times on snapchat and by good times
I mean dude kidding and make sure you
listen to this week's episode of not too
deep the full version on soundcloud and
i tune the links are down below it's a
really really wonderful conversation so
go check it out other than that
subscribe to this channel leave a
comment and like this video or don't are
you all musically now that's it it's
musically I recently learned about
musically and guys guys will talk about
earlier not in front of the new
subscribers I know it all
email was like dear Megan Wicky I was
like wait what what I was like are you
kidding me and yeah it was not even you
are able to rationalize like oh I'm not
crazy
no I'm not crazy my dog's got an email
okay I was like I was like you guys need
to come here and check this [ __ ]